I was in Palm Desert for a week oh
that's right what'd you do out there
nothing just hung by the pool and it's
like a you know Kelsey's family goes out
there every every uh year I did I did
plan out by the pool what just hung out
by the pool yeah slang and ball by the
pool yeah just
planted oh yeah hung out fully yeah yeah
swim shorts
no lining you're rolled up rolled up
straight up practicing your old guy
stuff yeah oh yeah practicing your set
creeping out of your [__] shirts and
then heading straight to the golf course
yeah dude where I hit a um a spectacular
145 I think I think the first day I shot
on don't look at me like that that's bad
I know I'm getting worse and it's
actually it's crazy it's wait wait wait
wait wait what explain 145 to me well I
mean like golf like you know the front
nine will have a par of like 35. okay
for example yeah so you have to get it
on 35 hits It's how many shots he took
and like if you got par if you hit par
on every single hole yeah then you would
wind up with like 35. and then the back
nine would be also 35 so like the par
the par of a course generally is like
what like 70 to 72 72 something like
that and I shot double which means like
on average I was doubling the amount of
Strokes you're supposed to take God and
at a certain point
I had to like I played the first time I
played I would take out my driver as
you're supposed to do yeah on when you
tee off you're supposed to use like the
club that hits the furthest farthest
whichever yeah and I would take out my
driver and I had to retire it after I
used it once because it became a safety
concern
like I there was one hole that was
bordering on the pool that everyone
shares they're all like these like
little time shares and everyone shares
like one pool so it's families kids
running around you can hear like
screaming people laughing and I hit my
driver somehow this is hard to do too
yeah the ball went straight up from the
Tee Box about three stories high okay
directly towards the pool okay and all
of us were like no no no no no no no
please please please and then and
and all we could hear in the distance is
oh my God
yeah yeah I'm kidding didn't hit anyone
but it did go straight you went back to
the hotel and there was just a kid
looking like a [__] ice cream with
like a gumball in it
just pure white
[Laughter]
I mean I had her am I gonna be okay it's
fine honey you're gonna be okay yeah
just blood running they look bad blood
running down the center of his head
vultures flying in Licking up his head
so you pulled out the Bazooka you
[__] launched one and then I put the
sleeve back on the head and stuck that
thing back in the bag didn't take it out
again for the rest of the dang the rest
of the round so yeah
like I'm getting worse at golf which I
don't even know how that's possible but
what would you do man didn't that didn't
that take like a major aspect out of
your game away
the driver yeah I could never really use
it oh okay so this wasn't really but it
never was like
you know like a concern like that it was
never like a oh we might get sued
because I'm using this club sure you
know it was always like I can't really
play but at least it goes forward got it
now it doesn't even go forward it goes
up and into the road or into the public
pool what do you think that is why do
you think you're getting worse because I
just suck and it's a shitty sport no one
should play it I agree with you now
I think it's a rich guy Sport and I
think if you play it
you suck you know who apparently
is a very um competent golfer whom
Freddy dread really yeah you ever seen
DJ khaled's tick tocks uh no bring some
of those up he loves golf he loves golf
every day check out the form now all
right now watch me bend my knees just a
little yeah
boom straight down the middle
straight down the middle does he have
like a golf account maybe he does Khalid
golfs he has a golf show coming out soon
Khalid wax
never mind okay once you check your uh
golf thread never mind follow your golf
buddies I don't have a I don't have a
golf thread all your AARP guys hey I
don't know if you're familiar with the
boys
what are we thinking tea times for this
weekend so what time was tea time
like eight a.m is that normal
I don't know it depends what's an
egregious tee time
um egregious yeah early yeah like are
you sick [__] I like right when the sun
comes up probably I think that's when
they start
or too late
and if you play too late and then you're
like fighting the sunset and starts to
get windy that's always shitty yeah I
remember in Hawaii we were staying at a
resort
it was connected to a golf course and
these guys were hitting them late in the
day they seemed very stressed
it was really funny stressed out in like
white khaki pants with gloves come on
come on come on come on
it was kind of funny there but
this is just another instance of me like
I shouldn't pick up clubs sure like
where we were saying it was on one of
the holes and so like you know as the
Sun starts to set the rounds are over so
you can like kind of just sneak out to
the course sure you know chip it onto
the green if you want yeah so we
probably stood like 100 yards from the
green and or like maybe 130 yards from
the grain okay both bring our pitching
wedge out there and there's like a dad
and his like little like toddler
daughters like standing like way off to
the right yeah and way off to the right
like
you know you sit the balls down you're
looking at the green you're like this is
where it's gonna go right you know what
I mean and so the first shot I hit goes
right again to right
and lands in the water right beside the
dad and he goes
I'm like I'm dude I'm so sorry oh no it
lands it lands on the actually on the
grass beside him and he looks at me and
goes like that what the [__] we hit a
couple more shots on the green we go and
get the balls bring them back and as
we're bringing them back he picks up my
ball and throws it in the water
I was like I deserve that 100
wow if my kids if you put my kids in
danger I would do the same thing now if
he did that I would have [__] just
pulled a t right out of my pocket put it
right down put the ball on top
and been like is there a [__] problem
yep is there a problem I would have been
like a machine in there go inside go
inside yeah like a 360. yeah every my
boy just put another ball down
the [__] out of here
damn so you almost killed two kids
yeah I mean and I hit a house sick
window I don't know if it was one that
would have made a huge bang it was loud
I want to go golfing another one just
straight up like
it's like I want to go golfing with you
but I just want to watch do you still
see your coach dumb as [__] you still
see your coach uh I've only ever gone to
him one time I'm gonna start going to
him again
because maybe he can teach me how to use
a driver but
one time I've taken one lesson you know
actually one of the things was he's like
you need clubs because I never had clubs
and so I got clubs
and uh and now I gotta go back to him
but the thing about getting clubs is he
I got fitted for clubs which is stupid I
got basically scammed
and and part of the fitting is you go
like wait just real quick everyone if
you were ever looking for someone to Rob
please
I'm good on the run I'm being wrong on
the scamming on the scamming part yeah
yeah if you sell Cody a magic golfing
pill do you think you fall for one yeah
like you take it take this supplement
and you only get 100 yeah
it enhances your vision changes your
game sense
part of what is like how the clubs mean
well they they you go to like a
simulator basically they they like you
know they make you play on a simulator
with and then they test you out with
different grips different shafts
different heads to see like what oh
oh yeah they make you grip different
shafts and yeah um they give you head
yeah different heads yeah um yeah
but basically they analyze and you know
you'd see like what you know how your
stroke is affected yeah so I went
through this whole thing and we did it
with the driver yeah tested out multiple
drivers yeah and like that was the one
that I could use the best and I cannot
[__] use that thing to save my life
damn
this is what it looks like Luke's
showing us yeah Cody's fitted clubs
uh they're made by Mattel
they come in fun colors green blue and
red but back to your Club fitting
so this guy sucks you off you buy it
you buy as you had he gives you a head
and then he makes you grip his shaft
yeah and then uh so that's the part
where you got scammed you woke up in his
bed you're like yeah
and then he still made me pay yeah
why do you have a bed in the back of the
shop hey you know man it gets crazy
sometimes things get into it
yeah so what do I owe you so you got
fitted for clubs and you can't use them
at all yeah so now that cost you a
pretty penny
yeah that's what I'm saying I got
scammed because uh so they made you hit
I didn't I don't really know that much
about golf I like playing it you know
I've grown up sort of playing it I
played it like once every year or
something like that yeah but like I
don't know how much they're supposed to
cost so easy thing so I told him how
much I paid for them and they were like
what
24 Karat that's them oh my God are you
kidding me oh my god dude bust down
putter oh my God they came off the gold
standard and all these old people were
like yep yep
government don't know I have 40 pounds
of gold in my house that is that is like
royalty right there that's pretty sick I
mean I bet they suck though yeah hitting
with solid gold no way wouldn't that be
like super heavy yeah
this this sound would be awful too
you look sick though yeah
yeah they cost me an arm and a leg and
some head
why not
do you think there's any shot you can
improve
yeah I mean I I you just kind of
practice I don't go to the driving range
and you do right sometimes yeah
sometimes but you play like it often I
play two to three times a month and then
I go to the range pretty often three
times yeah I mean you part of a club
part of a little country club can't
afford that just like the local yeah
good we don't pay enough for that that's
good that one tasks actually part of a
club but oh oh it doesn't play well no
I'm sorry no I'm not
hahaha
no I'm actually part of the Bel Air Club
there's a golf roast right there
that's nice dude
yeah Cody's part of the Bel Air Club
everyone listening got that yeah
everyone listening is definitely
laughing they understand everyone knows
the waiting list is years
holy [__]